across London there are pockets where
Russia's billionaires have their homes
that's Roman Abramovich is house there's
one of Andre Gunther renko's four homes
in the middle of the capital
Leonard Levitt Nick the billionaire
philanthropist lives there these are
homes valued at tens of millions of
pounds a cluster of Russian jewels a
short stroll from Buckingham Palace a
house is refurbished Russian money is
employing people here paying for all
this work this is the roof terrace below
us we've got these cinema we've got
staff changing area staff bedrooms
service kitchens the staff and for a
commercial kitchen full potential in the
client and then below that we've got a
cinema steam room experience shower and
a gym area and when this project is
finished it'll be a home worth around 30
million pounds everything must be to the
best standards possible money is no
object London does benefit from having
wealthy foreign investors whose money
trickles down through employment and
spending but there are other Russians in
the UK whose wealth is now under
scrutiny and some have suggested
economic sanctions against them as a way
of punishing Vladimir Putin
there are more than a hundred thousand
Russians in London alone including the
owner of this high-end wine shop a man
who made a fortune in the Russian mobile
phone business before being exiled by
Putin's government probably I will never
come back how does that make you feel
quite upset he is no friend of Huijin
so would he welcome sanctions against
Russia's oligarchs what you should do to
punish vitamin Putin my answer is punish
Latimer pretty Putin personally how do
we do not people who lived here for 15
or 20 years it doesn't it doesn't work
and if some oligarch who lives here and
will be sanctions against them and Putin
will say yeah I was right they are
enemies back home take your money
finish your investment back home to
Russia who who is the winner put him so
maybe that's the challenge how to decide
between those who bring legitimate
investments of the UK and those whose
money is more open to scrutiny Roman
borisovitch was once a senior executive
at Russia's largest insurance company
now he campaigns for transparency and he
brought us to look at a luxury flat in
the heart of Westminster with black
railings actually a double apart two
apartments combined were purchased by
the fifth most powerful bureaucrat in
Russia after Vladimir Putin
igor ivanovich wallop deprecate with
Deputy Prime Minister who is in charge
of the economy and finance what this
place for an equivalent of a hundred and
twelve of his annual declared incomes
the challenge is proving corruption and
that often starts with tracing where
unexplained wealth actually comes from
you can quite legally buy a property in
this country using an offshore company
to cover your identity makes the money a
lot harder to follow and some say that's
a recipe for money laundering but there
are thousands of properties in the UK
sold in that way
this is lounge square in central London
and here 40% of the properties are
registered to anonymous offshore
companies it makes this the most secret
street in Britain and there are now
growing calls for the government to do
more to investigate this sort of hidden
wealth there are now greater powers to
investigate notably unexplained wealth
orders which allow police to force
people to explain how they became
wealthy but some stony convincing that
the UK is serious about chasing down GBS
money vladimir asha cough is a russian
dissident who now lives in london of
course there is the lobby of enablers of
kleptocrats this lawyer's property state
agents bankers that service this corrupt
flow even in a democratic political
system like Britain's there are special
interests that would like to skew the
government policy in certain direction
and one of such influences is of course
that Britain would turn a blind eye to
corrupt money so how's the UK really
been lacks in its pursuit of money
laundering it's a claim we put to the
government I don't think by any
government it was a premeditated mistake
I don't think they sat down and
deliberately said well we're not going
to do anything about it but I think what
they did was they were focusing on other
priorities at the time and we have
committed with draft legislation we do
this year or and next year we'll
hopefully introduce it on forcing
oversea
companies and overseas individuals who
own property in the United Kingdom to
register that in a public register so
we'll all be able to know who owns what
in London Britain is a country that
welcomes wealthy foreigners and that
brings benefits and challenges if there
is a move here it is a slow flight from
secrecy to transparency Adam Parsons Sky
News